I think my favorite thing about the concept for the diet Coke TV ad that we just shot...
...is that one of the most amazing things about what I get to do...
...is watching the process of writing a song.
And then all the next steps that happen resulting in someone singing it in their car,...
...someone singing it in their bedroom.
I write on whatever I can find.
I write wherever I am,...
...whenever I get an idea.
In the middle of the day, in the middle of the night.
And I like that the commercial just really showcased that.
I think one of my favorite things about the red tour is that...
...one of the main focuses I had was incorporating the element of surprise...
...and incorporating the unexpected.
I like to think that a good concert can be like a good book.
It can take you away.
It can take you to a different place and help you escape.
And I think that's the main goal for me:...
...helping the fans to escape if only just for one night, you know.